and what I'll try to do is I'll just I  write long-handed on so on a legal pad  I'll go goes to here sees his mother  goes to the store goes so I'll have like  10 things uh of Beats where he's going  um gets on a horse goes swimming boom  boom boom and I do that and I know in my  heart 80 of it will be no good but  you're getting through the screenplay  you're getting it done because the  rewrite is always more fun and much more  enjoyable it's I don't believe people  should look for profession or even 50  profession in the first draft it's  always going to be kind of this like a  child scribbling but you did it and the  main thing for me is to once you have  that accomplishment let's say in two you  could do it in two weeks three weeks  again maybe 10 percent will be good but  you've now had this sense of accomplish  you did it and the rewriting process  starts and that's when the fun begins